leute wir sind heute auf einer
ritterburg wir feiern fordert episoden
lernen und wir haben euch gebieten eure
videos zu schicken und sagen warum ihr
zusammen mit und wenn wir jetzt mal
hallo lieber von superman
wir sind wirklich werden ihr macht die
videodienst hassani teenager und wir
kommen aus pittsburgh pennsylvania
hallo liebe leute vom pc gamern ich bin
oft ja ich komme aus kuba und vorne die
ja in japan
hallo mein name to become com höher
halo ist in rollen aus taiwan hallo ich
heiße aktie und ist vorne dabei
hallo leute mein name
[Musik]
ist heiß ersehnt und ist vom austausch
gegen zehn jahre alte australier david
und in london den usa hallo
[Musik]
ich bin eine mentalität ab wenn diese
nicht wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dankeschön carina fließt in seinem 37 st
ich freue mich auf die nächste zwei
folgen aus der ich komme extra humor
connelly web große liebe gefunden leute
ihr seid echt der hammer
leute ihr leben durch martin gefilde
zurück und wir reden über den schönsten
moment war ihr schönster individuellen
moment wahrscheinlich zweimal habe ich
durch die tür man eine wohnung in london
gefunden
ja wir haben ja einmal das video in
berlin gedreht wie man eine wohnung in
der großstadt findet er aber das hat
auch geklappt
genau und dann habe ich ja den appell
gestartet ja und darauf hatte sich da
niemand gemeldet und ich bin tatsächlich
kann in london in das wg zimmer
eingezogen
das hat super funktioniert genau und der
zweite moment war die idee german summer
school ist ja genau vier tage in berlin
mit leuten aus israel italien indonesien
holland ungarn usa genau war supergeil
und findet ja dieses jahr wieder statt
und ich freue mich auf jeden fall wieder
vorbei zu schauen wenn ich eigentlich
das ganze für die ganze zeit mit dabei
sein kann ja immer willkommen sie wird
ein schönes tor 12
also einer geht's vier wochen lang war
die usa reise die im netzwerk gemacht
haben da gab es sehr viele schöne
momente deswegen wird jetzt kam aus unna
diese reise war einfach unglaublich
schön werden so viele tolle menschen
kennen und hatten spaß ohne ende und der
zweite war als erster alle karneval bei
mir war das eine fahne freude betont
stappert dass wir die tradition jedes
jahr bitte war fast in köln wir drehen
immer schöne karneval jetzt das heißt
wir müssen jeden kamera zu bekommen und
sie können ja auch dann meine ingenieure
partys rechte an der ecke auf der straße
wer gern laden alle ein und sagen ab
werk straßenecke jetzt die branding wird
vorher anwesend sein können weil das was
macht man kommt ihr einfach alles vorbei
und sein
jetzt aber bitte wir werden auch nicht
weniger
doch wer wir sind
china gehen immer total toll weil ich
viel gelernt habe
vor allem die aussprache ich lerne heute
feiere es gut klingt
wir lernen deutsch ungefähr fünf jahren
machen so viel spaß ich studiere deutsch
23 jahren bei sieht meine austauschjahr
in deutschland machen will
sie türmen war oscar ist ein guter
lehrer katholisch ist lieber die
deutsche kultur wirtschaft die autos
wären die leute und im fußball ist
irgendwie diesem an weil sie schon mir
wirklich viel bei deutschland gefunden
hat
danke mich sehr und auch gleich mal ohne
visum kann ich nicht mehr leben der
erfahrungen die die wieder man schaut
geht sein
ich halte ein achter interessen machen
werde
ich werde deutsch weil ich in
deutschland ich habe viele gute sachen
gelernt zum beispiel die man gemacht hat
ganz besonders wasserbett in betrieben
das finde ich ziemlich krass eine infame
sich schauen zusammen weil trug meinen
die nach
denn ich möchte in deutschland und ich
selber gewählt hat uns sehr geholfen um
uns zu verbessern wenn wir ihn hier
die episoden sprechen interessante
themen ansprechen ist relativ man über
die deutschen durch und fördern die
offenheit
zum schluss müssen wir euch für eure
fünf jahre arbeit danken unseren beitrag
in der 200 episoden von itg man werde
für uns groß für einen fehler denn dein
schönster in diesem moment ich glaube
das lustigste da an das was ich mich nur
war als martin und ich damals entweder
das erste mal in berlin besuchen
gekommen sind und dann sind wir
irgendwie aus dem auto ausgestiegen
haben wir euch geklingelt du kommst raus
und es kam zwei siemens fans zufällig
glaube irgendwie aus korea oder und
ägypten und aber auch noch irgendwer auf
korea oder so ich weiß nicht und die
haben sich direkt erkannt
die haben sich ja ich weiß aber noch
nicht ob das fake war die haben sich
dann erst mal halb so schön zugehört das
wollte ich auch am meisten wenn und
leute erkennen auf der straße ist sehr
schön das passiert auch mittlerweile
sehr auf aber auch meine lieblings
momente sind die begegnung also so ein
video drehen macht ihr spaß und das ist
auch witzig wenn wir zum beispiel auf
der ritterburg rumrennen aber wenn man
die leute wie das drucken die sich
darauf freuen und ihnen das wirklich was
bringt also die persönliche begegnung
ist das album am start sein
eure kommentare die meisten zumindest
genau das zu machen was wir tun das ist
euch gefällt gucken wir einfach noch mal
ein paar von euren videos an diesen
service
eine geniale gesehen ein ideales projekt
richtet seit 200 folgen funktioniert und
wenn ich zurückdenke als die folgen als
nächstes beteiligt war dann feucht weil
es doch wunderschöne tage war ich
verbrachte für karry diana schmidt wenn
mit diesen ist lustig und einfach auf
der straße wo auf geräusche vor großen
erfolg freuen ich komme aus brüder und
ich sehe diese firmen an um ein deutsch
zu verbessern weil ich hier in
deutschland vorher hallo ii die german
smart adserver wir lieben euch und
lieben was wir tun also herzlichen glück
und ein bisschen glück wohnt hat mich im
glück wo und wie frei
hallo liebe zu scharf
ich bin russendisko herzlich willkommen
im sonnigen sind in sachen
ich bin gerade im gleichen ort oder sie
ziehen ihr video über die unterschiede
zwischen deutschland und den usa gedreht
hat ist kugelsicheren weil er so
wahnsinnig hilfreich ist
insbesondere fall meint fischer hallo
ich bin's ich wenigsten 8000 ausfüllen
auf kabarett und will man ja leute das
um 32 hundertstel episode wir haben uns
wahnsinnig gefreut oder alu videos danke
danke danke für diese ganzen stellen
videos
sehr gefreut gesehen sehr sehr schöner
geht das herz auf richtig schön aber
erstmal da wofür man es macht vettweiß
jetzt weiß ich endlich erfolg haben weiß
ich warum ich das mache
wegen euch und wir werden euch demnächst
öfter mal anrufen um uns wir verschicken
zu verschiedenen aufrufen
[Musik]
ich sage euch um die superstars die
besser auf dem man ja leute das war
unsere 200 episode the german mit den
besten videos von euch und wir gewinnen
die deutschen offener ritterburg und auf
dieser ritterburg haben wir auch leute
interviews und gekuppelt sie gibt ganz
die mittel also die waren die sie hat
mich einige nächte vorher sehr beeilen
und das internet derzeit und wieder ein
mit- woche bei german
[Musik]